look man
i'm an innovator
and i'm not here to sit up and apologize
about my ideas
kanye west is clapping back at critics
in a rare interview it's extremely
important to me after the rapper and
designer was slammed for his latest
yeezy gap collaboration he set the
record straight on fox and friends this
is like not a joke this is not a game
this is not just some celebrity
collaboration this is my life you know
i'm i'm fighting for a position to be
able to change clothing and bring
the best design to the people
yay first announced his collab back in
2020 which received harsh criticism
online one user tweeted they were
selling the clothes out of giant trash
bags and claimed the sales associates
said yay got mad when he saw they had it
on hangers and this is how he wanted it
now yay says his vision is being
misunderstood and the goal was always to
make getting dressed easier just do
something for my heart to be fair kanye
previously shared this in a now deleted
instagram post look to the children look
to the homeless as the biggest
inspiration for all design do you
understand
some people felt that putting clothes in
bags is insensitive perhaps to homeless
and other people
look man
i'm an innovator
and i'm not here to sit up and apologize
about my ideas
that's exactly what the media tries to
do
makers apologize for any idea that
doesn't fall under
exactly
the way they want us to think we hear
you loud and clear yay and despite
public backlash he has his family's full
support for the yeezy brand you know he
might say things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart estranged wife kim
kardashian and their daughter chicago
and north recently sported his
futuristic yeezy sunglasses and we love
to see the west kids enjoying some good
family time as for kim and kanye's
relationship amid their ongoing divorce
a source tells e.t things are cordial
between them adding kim and kanye have
been co-parenting in a healthy way
lately while we're told communication
has been improving between the two they
may have hit a bump in the road since
kim split from pete davidson
it's likely kim wasn't thrilled about
kanye posting this meme a fake cover of
the new york times that read skeet
davidson dead at age 28.
another source told us pete is seeking
trauma therapy help in large part due to
kanye's constant threats and public
attacks like all i can do is control how
i react to something i can't control
what other people do how he treats me
[Music]
you